[Music]
hey friends Drex here from drexfactor
pulley sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain so I recently taught a
private lesson on how to do stalls and I
came up with a pretty awesome way to get
these down stalls in a pretty intuitive
fashion that I wanted to share with you
all but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
pekunen thank you so very much for
support supporting my channel my work
and my mission so stalls they're super
useful as a transition tool if you're
trying to switch the direction of the
pulley back and forth or switch the
timing of them stalls are really really
helpful for doing that they're also kind
of a pain in the butt because they
require us to have a pretty good level
of control over the Poise momentum and
how to get it to stop now I personally
have a way that I like visualizing
stalls wherein the path that the POI
travels is kind of like a circle and
there's a box that goes around that
circle touching it in four points now
when we perform our stalls what we're
actually doing is we're bringing our POI
head up to touch each of the corners of
that box and that is what makes the
Stalls work the whole idea here is that
once the POI passes by that point where
there's an intersection between the box
and the circle our next move is to get
our hand out to that same intersection
and once we do so that'll cause the POI
head to travel straight along along the
edge of the box for one POI length and
that will get it to stop this works
whether the POI is stalling down up top
side
or across
like so that's great in theory but how
do we actually do it in practice so glad
you asked I recently had a private
lesson wherein I taught this to somebody
who was kind of struggling with it and I
found a new approach to teaching it so
that's what we're going to go through so
first up a word on things that make
stalls a little bit easier to accomplish
for one thing if you use heavier POI
heads paradoxically having more mass
actually mix stalls a little bit easier
to get into the other thing I will say
is shortening up your POI can help out a
lot so if you've got longer POI you can
wrap them around your hand once in order
to get a shorter version of that POI and
shorter tethers definitely help when
you're first starting out as you get
more comfortable with your stalls though
definitely challenge yourself to perform
them with longer POI so we're going to
start off like this you're going to take
the pull in your dominant hand and
you're going to spin it so that it is
coming down across your non-dominant
side my diamond hand is my right hand so
I'm spinning my POI counterclockwise
relative to me that way the POI is
coming down over on my left side makes
sense it's going up past my right elbow
down past my right shoulder all right so
our next move is that we're going to try
and catch the POI head when it's
straight out to the side that is when
it's pointing straight over to the left
from my right hand like so the way we're
going to do this is I'm going to have my
left hand reach out in front of me and
I'm going to just sweep it in to let the
POI head drop into my hand as it's
coming down from above
all right so the next move here is that
once I catch the POI head in my left
hand my right hand is going to reach out
to my left to meet that other hand this
is not going to be my left hand comes in
to meet my right hand it's my right hand
reaching over to my left to catch up
with the left really important I need to
underscore this when you catch that POI
head it's your dominant hand that
reaches out to catch up with it it's not
a case where your non-dominant hand is
coming in to meet the other one or that
the two hands are coming together it's
very much I'm catching with my left hand
my left hand doesn't move it's my right
hand that goes up to meet it yeah all
right so once you get comfortable doing
the catch and come in catch and come in
catch and come in I want you to work on
narrowing the amount of time between
those two things so catch come in right
away catch come in right away catch come
in right away catch come in right away
just like that alright so the last step
of this is we're going to take out the
catch entirely what's going to happen
instead is you're going to imagine that
you've caught that POI head and then
immediately bring out your dominant hand
to that same point you're going to
imagine the catch happened bring your
hand out and what's going to happen
instead is that the POI head is going to
drop down a full POI length and as your
dominant hand is coming out towards the
point where you would have caught it you
wind up with this place where the POI
head stops moving and the POI just winds
up hanging there beneath your hand so
again the steps of this are we're going
to catch the POI head catch the POI head
catch the POI head and then we catch
bring the dominant hand over
catch bring the dominant hand over
catch bring the dominant hand over then
we do it faster catch pull
catch pull
catch pull and then we take the catch
out entirely and we just bring out our
hand as the POI is passing by that
position out to the side of it and this
should give us a really really clean
down stall
like that so after a few repetitions
getting that down again it's really
helpful to practice this looking at
yourself in a mirror try going the other
way so after you've done the stall
you'll pull your hand back to Center and
bring the POI head up above it and try
bringing it down to your dominant side
your non-dominant side your dominant
side your non-dominant side going back
and forth just like this cool so once
this gets to feel comfortable you can
try it letting out the point of full
length and see how that works for you
you're going to have to make a few
adjustments just because the greater
length means that you're going to have
to let your hand travel out more in
order to get the POI to drop a full POI
length down in order to complete the
stall but other than that yeah this is
the recipe to at least get down those
down stalls
and as you get more comfortable with
this you can start to get a little bit
more extra with it maybe explore the
space around you a little bit more and
use a little bit more hand motion to
complete those stalls in different
places around you but this right here
this is the basic motion that you want
to get down in order to get into the
other stuff cool I really hope this was
helpful if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to leave me a
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find the video and of
course to help my channel grow
foreign
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these awesome
people right here they along with the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you're out there watching
are not currently a supporter but would
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to check
out more beginner POI lessons that I've
done I will go ahead and leave a link to
a playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video based upon some of
your other past viewing choices so maybe
give that a look as well thanks so much
for watching make sure to get outside
the flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon
peace